Speaker 1: So we've been having a conversation
now for what, a year close to a year or a little
longer about the Partizan uptake of the COVID
vaccines and one of the most anti-vaccine groups
today. With regard to the COVID vaccines is
Republicans and in particular Trump voters.
Non-Trump voting Republicans are slightly
less anti-vax than Trump voting Republicans
who are like the most anti-vax. And we know why
this has happened. We know about the way that
their view on the vaccines has reversed simply
because Donald Trump is no longer in office and
now Joe Biden is. And we've talked also about
the increasingly Partizan COVID deaths, where
much more now by an almost 50 percent higher rate.
The cumulative COVID death rate in Trump counties
is higher than in Biden voting counties. They're
killing themselves at a disproportionately high
rate relative to Democrats, and at some point
it may make an electoral difference. But we now
have new data and this is going beyond just the
COVID vaccine. The acceptance of the flu vaccine,
as we now are getting into and into
flu season in the United States
is also heavily Partizan, and it didn't used
to be. You used to see almost identical levels
of flu vaccination from Democrats, as you saw
from Republicans, no more. We have the data
and the data is quite detailed. Flu shot uptake
is now Partizan, and it didn't used to be so.
We have two polls from flu shot uptake
right now, OK? According to Ipsos,
68 percent of Democrats said they have gotten
a flu shot or are very likely to get one,
whereas only 44 percent of Republicans
said the same. So that's a 24 point gap
between Democrats and Republicans on the flu
shot, similar to the COVID gap that exists. A
second poll from this year shows the same thing
65 percent of Democrats said they did or will
definitely get a flu shot, and only 40 percent
of Republicans. That's a 25 point Partizan gap
on the flu shot. That's not the way it always
used to be. For example, last year there was an AP
NORC poll and it said, Did you get a flu shot in
the last year in that poll? Fifty eight percent of
Democrats said I got a flu shot in the last year,
whereas only 54 percent of Republicans did. That
was a four point gap. It's almost the margin of
error. OK, so you used to have almost even flu
shot acceptance between Republicans and Democrats.
Now you have a gap where by 24 25 points,
Democrats are significantly more vaccinated
against the flu, as are Republicans. Another
data point about past Partizan gap. If you look
at a 2016 study from Princeton Survey Research,
yet 55 percent of Democrats and 53 percent of
Republicans saying I got a flu shot in the last
12 months. So there was almost no Partizan gap
whatsoever. So in all seriousness? Are Republicans
hurting themselves electorally because of this, if
they just keep doing it at some point, is going to
start impacting your population? We've had so
let's let's talk about what's not new. Science
has had a Partizan divide for a long time, so
take the issue of climate change. For decades now,
the right has disproportionately
rejected the science on climate,
including the reality that humans are
impacting the changing climate on planet Earth.
Republicans have rejected that. Now the thing
about climate is it mostly affects everybody,
regardless of partizanship. Now you can make
the case well, the more we burn fossil fuels,
poor people disproportionately are downwind from
the emissions from burning fossil fuels. So it
really it's causing more cancer in poor people.
And to the extent that there's a Partizan divide
there. OK, so you you can make a case. This is
just straight up Partizan with the vaccines. The
Republicans are disproportionately not getting
vaccinated against COVID. The Republicans are
now also, as of this year, disproportionately
not getting vaccinated against the flu. At a
certain point, you're going to kill your own
voters, and it could make a difference now.
We've looked at the data. What would it take
to make a difference? There was this example,
and I'll talk through the generalities of it, but
we should really look at the data again back in.
Let me see what it was. Florida gubernatorial
election results when Ron DeSantis ran in 2018.
Ron DeSantis won by 0.4 percent over Andrew Gillum
Gillum. I forget the pronunciation now. It was a
difference of 33000 votes. 33000 votes were the
margin for Ron DeSantis in Florida as governor
in the year 2018. Now in Florida, there are
61000 COVID deaths that we know of, and there are
very serious questions about the degree to which
Florida is coming, even close to reporting all
the deaths from from COVID. So if there's 60000,
there's probably really at least 70000. Let's pick
that number. If they were evenly split between
Democrats and Republicans, 70000 COVID deaths
would mean 35000 Democrats and 35000 Republicans.
Now, if you have a Partizan gap there,
if you imagine well, if the Florida data tracks
the national data and Republicans are dying at,
let's call it a 50 percent higher rate. All of a
sudden, those 70000 deaths might look more like
50000 Republicans and 20000 Democrats.
That's a 30000 death gap. The margin
for victory for DeSantis was only about 33000
ballots in 2018, so you can very quickly see how.
If this continues to go on and the Partizan gap
is there on COVID deaths because of vaccination,
and we start to see a Partizan gap on flu deaths
again, because Republicans are now starting to
reject the flu vaccine as well. In Florida,
it's totally plausible that as a result of
deaths from COVID and flu alone, it could flip
an election from a Republican governor to a
Democratic governor. OK. Those are the numbers in
Florida. We'd have to see where else this applies.
This is a reality, and I'm not giving
Republicans advice if they're not
worried about this and they're not realizing how
quickly the numbers could go against them here.
It's their problem. But you would think even if
they don't care about the human tragedy of these
deaths, that they would care about the electoral
consequences that potentially could happen. So
that's the latest on flu shot. And we're going
to continue watching how those numbers look